MALE SPEAKER: The following
content is provided under a
Creative Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation, or to view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Hi.
Last time, we had discussed
series and sequences.
Today, we're going to turn our
attention to a rather special
situation, a situation in which
every term in our series
is positive.
For this reason, I have entitled
today's lecture
'Positive Series'.
Before we can do full justice
to positive series, however,
there are a few topics that we
must discuss as preliminaries.
The first of these is simply
the process of ordering.
Now this is a rather
strange situation.
Because in the finite
case, it turns out
to be rather trivial.
By way of illustration, let's
suppose the set 'S' consists
of the numbers 11,
8, 9, 7, and 10.
Now there are many ways
in which we could
order the set 'S'.
We can arrange them so that any
one of these five elements
comes first, any one
of the remaining
four second, et cetera.
But suppose that we want
to arrange these
according to size.
Observe that there is a rather
straightforward, shall we say,
binary technique, whereby we
can order these elements.
By binary, I mean, let's look
at these two at the time.
We look at 11 and 8, and we
throw away the larger of the
two, which is 11.
Then we compare 8 with
9, throwaway 9
because that's bigger.
Compare 8 and 7, throw away 8.
Compare 7 and 10,
throw away 10.
The survivor, being 7, is
therefore the least member of
our collection.
In a similar way, we can delete
7 and start looking for
the next number of our set.
And in this way, eventually
order the elements of 'S'
according to size--
7, 8, 9, 10, 11.
OK.
Clearly, 7 is the smallest
element of 'S' and 11 is the
largest element of S.
And in terms of nomenclature, we
say that 7 is a lower bound
for 'S', 11 is an upper
bound for 'S'.
You see, in terms of a picture,
all we're saying is
that when the elements of 'S'
are ordered according to size,
7 is the furthest to
the left, 11 is the
furthest to the right.
We could even talk more about
the nomenclature by saying--
and this sounds like
a tongue twister.
This is why I had you read this
material first in the
last assignment and the
supplementary notes, so that
part of this will at least
seem like a review.
Observe that 7 is called the
greatest lower bound for 'S',
simply because any number larger
than 7 cannot be a
lower bound for 'S', simply
because 7 would be smaller
than that particular number.
And in a similar way, 11 is
called the least upper bound
for 'S', because any number
smaller than 11 would be
exceeded by 11, and hence
could not be an
upper bound for 'S'.
Now the interesting
point is this.
Hopefully, at this stage of the
game, you listened to what
I've had to say, and you say,
my golly, this is trivial.
And the answer is,
it is trivial.
But remember what our main
concern was in our last
lecture when we introduced the
concept of infinite series and
sequences--
that many things that were
trivial for the finite case
became rather serious dilemmas
for the infinite case.
In other words, my claim is
that these results are far
more subtle for infinite sets.
And I think the best
way to do this is
by means of an example.
See now, let 'S' be the set of
numbers where the n-th number
is 'n' over 'n + 1'.
In other words, the first member
of 'S' will be 1/2, the
second member, 2/3, the third
member, 3/4, et cetera.
Now, let's take look to see
what the least upper
bound for 'S' is.
And sparing you the details, I
think you can observe at this
stage of the game, especially
based on the homework of the
last unit, that the limit of
the sequence 'S' is 1.
In fact, 1 is the smallest
number which exceeds every
member in this collection.
In other words, 1 is the least
upper bound for 'S'.
But observe the interesting
case that here--
and by the way, notice the
abbreviation that we use in
our notes. 'LUB', least
upper bound.
'GLB', greatest lower bound.
But 1 is the least upper
bound for 'S'.
Yet the fact remains that the
least upper bound is not a
member of 'S' itself.
In other words, there is no
number 'n' such that 'n' over
'n + 1' is equal to 1.
You see, notice that as these
numbers increase, they get
bounded by 1, but 1 is
not a member of 'S'.
In other words, here's an
example where the least upper
bound of a set does not have
to be a member of the set.
And a companion to this would
be an example where the
greatest lower bound is not
a member of the set.
And to this end, simply let
the n-th member of 'S'
arranged by sequence be '1/n'.
The n-th member is '1/n'.
Therefore, 'S' is what?
The set consisting of 1,
1/2, 1/3, et cetera.
Observe that as the terms go
further and further out, they
get arbitrarily close
to 0 in size--
every one of these terms, '1/n',
no matter how big 'n'
is is greater than 0.
In other words, then, observe
that 0 will be the greatest
lower bound for 'S', but 0
is not a member of 'S'.
In other words, it seems that
things which are quite trivial
for finite collections have
certain degrees of
sophistication for infinite
collections.
So what we're going to do now
is to establish a few basic
definitions.
And we'll do it in a
rather formal way.
Our first definition
is the following.
Given the set of numbers, 'S',
'M' is called an upper bound
for 'S', If 'M' is greater than
or equal to 'x' for all
'x' in 'S'.
In other words, if 'M' exceeds
every member of 'S', 'M' is
called an upper bound for 'S'.
As I say, these these
definitions are very
straightforward.
The companion--
well, let's go one
step further.
By the way, observe that I
have in the interest of
brevity left out the
corresponding definitions for
lower bounds.
But they are quite analogous.
In other words, a lower bound
for 'S' would be a number that
was less than or equal to
each member in 'S'.
At any rate, then, 'M' is called
a least upper bound for
'S' if first of all, 'M' is
an upper bound for 'S'.
And secondly, if 'L' is less
than 'M', 'L' is not an upper
bound for 'S'.
In other words, least upper
bound means what?
Anything smaller cannot
be an upper bound.
Notice in terms of our previous
remark that the least
upper bound need not
belong to 'x'.
The companion to this
would be what?
A greatest lower bound would be
a number which is a lower
bound such that anything
greater could
not be a lower bound.
Again, all of this is easier to
see in terms of a picture.
Visualize 'S' as being this
interval with little 'm' and
capital 'M' being the endpoints
of the interval.
Observe that capital 'M' is
the least upper bound.
Little 'm' is the greatest
lower bound.
Anything smaller than little
'm' will be lower bound.
Anything greater than capital
'M' will be an upper bound.
And notice that nothing in the
set 'S' itself can be either
an upper bound or
a lower bound.
Because anything inside 'S'
appears to the right of little
'm' and to the left
of capital 'M'.
And one final definition
as a preliminary.
A set, 'S', is called bounded if
it has both an upper and a
lower bound.
And the key property that
we have to keep track of
throughout this--
and we won't prove this.
In other words, in more
rigorous advanced math
courses, this is proven
as a theorem.
For our purposes, it seems
self-evident enough so that
we're willing to accept it.
And so rather than to belabor
the point, let us just accept
as a key property that every
bounded set of numbers has a
greatest lower bound and
at least upper bound.
In other words, if a set is
bounded, we can find a
smallest upper bound and
a largest lower bound.
And this completes the
first portion of
our preliminary material.
The next portion of our
preliminary material before
studying positive series
involves what we mean by a
monotonic non-decreasing
sequence.
A sequence is called monotonic
non-decreasing--
and if you don't frighten at
these words, it's almost
self-evident what this
thing means.
It means that no term can
be smaller than the
one that came before.
In other words, the n-th term
is less than or equal to the
'n plus first term'
for each 'n'.
And wording that more
explicitly, it says what?
'a sub 1' is less than or equal
to 'a sub 2' is less
than or equal to 'a
sub 3', et cetera.
And I hope that it's clear by
this time that it's not
self-evident that a sequence
has to have this.
Remember the subscripts simply
tell you the order in which
the terms appear.
It has no bearing on the
size of the term.
For example, in an arbitrary
sequence, recall that the
second term can be smaller in
magnitude than the first term.
However, if the terms are
non-decreasing sequentially
this way, the sequence
is called monotonic
non-decreasing.
And the problem that comes up
is, or the important question
that comes up is, what's so
important about monotonic
non-decreasing sequences?
And the answer is that for
such sequences, two
possibilities exist.
In other words, either the terms
can keep getting larger
and larger without bound--
see?
In other words, that the
sequences 'a sub n' has no
upper bound.
In which case, we say that the
limit of 'a sub n' as 'n'
approaches infinity
is infinity.
And for example, the
ordinary counting
sequence has this property.
See, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, et cetera,
is a monotonic
non-decreasing sequence.
In fact, it's monotonic
increasing.
Every member of the sequence is
greater than the one that
came before.
But as you go further and
further out, the terms
increase without upper bound.
OK?
Now what is the other
possibility for a monotonic
non-decreasing sequence?
After all, the opposite, or the
only other possibility, is
that if the 'a sub n'-- if it's
false, that the sequence
doesn't have an upper bound,
then of course it must have an
upper bound.
That's the second case.
In other words, suppose the
sequence has an upper bound.
Then the interesting point
is that the limit of this
sequence exists.
And not only does it exist, but
the limit itself is the
least upper bound
of the sequence.
In other words, in the case
where the sequence is
non-decreasing, if
it's bounded--
if it's bounded--
the least upper bound
will be the limit.
Now you see, here's where we
use that key property.
Namely, if a sequence is
bounded, it must have a least
upper bound.
Let's call that least
upper bound 'L'.
And by the way, you'll notice
I wrote the word proof in
quotation marks.
It's simply to indicate that I
prefer to give you a geometric
proof here rather than
an analytic one.
But the analytic proof
follows word for
word from this picture.
In other words, it just
translates in the usual way.
And we'll drill on this with
the exercises and the notes
and the textbook.
But at any rate, the
idea is this.
To prove that 'L' is a limit,
what must I do?
I must show that if I choose
any epsilon greater than 0,
that all the terms beyond a
certain one lie between 'L
minus epsilon' and
'L plus epsilon'.
Now here's the way this works.
Let's see if we can just read
the diagram and get this thing
very quickly.
First of all, at least one term
in my sequence has to be
between 'L minus epsilon'
and 'L'.
And the reason for that
is simply this.
Remember 'L' is a least
upper bound.
Because 'L' is a least upper
bound, 'L minus epsilon'
cannot be an upper bound.
Now if no term can get beyond
'L minus epsilon', then
certainly 'L minus epsilon'
would be an upper bound.
The fact that 'L minus epsilon'
isn't an upper bound,
therefore, means that at least
one 'a sub n', say 'a sub
capital N', is in this
interval here.
Notice also that because 'L' is
an upper bound, no 'a sub
n' can get beyond here.
In other words, no 'a
sub n' lies between
'L' and 'L plus epsilon'.
Because in that particular case,
if that were to happen,
'L' couldn't be an
upper bound.
OK, so far, so good.
That follows just from
the definition of
the least upper bound.
Now, we use the fact that the
sequence is non-decreasing.
And that says what?
That if little 'n' is greater
than capital 'N', 'a sub
little n' is greater than or
equal to 'a sub capital N'.
In other words, what this means
is if you list the 'a
sub n's along this line, as 'n'
increases, the terms move
progressively from
left to right.
In other words, notice then that
if 'n' is greater than or
equal to capital 'N', 'L minus
epsilon' is less than 'a sub
capital N', which in turn is
less than or equal to 'a sub
little n', which in turn is
less than or equal to 'L'.
And that's just another
geometric way of saying that
'a sub n' is within
epsilon of 'L'.
And that's exactly the
definition that the 'a sub n's
converge to the limit 'L'.
Now I went over this rather
quickly simply because this is
done in the textbook.
And all I'm trying to do with
this lecture is to give you a
quick overview of
what's going on.
Well, you see, we're now roughly
15 minutes into our
lecture and we haven't come
to the main topic yet.
My claim is that the main
topic works very, very
smoothly once we understand
these preliminaries.
The main topic, you see, is
called positive series.
And the definition of a positive
series is just as the
name implies.
If each term in the series is
at least as great as 0-- in
other words, if each term
is non-negative--
then the series is
called positive.
Now why are positive
series important?
And why do they tie in with
our previous discussion?
Well, let's answer the
last question.
The reason they tie in with
our previous discussion is
that we have already seen that
by the sum of a series, we
mean the limit of the sequence
of partial sums.
To go from one partial sum to
the next, you add on the next
term in the series.
If each of the 'a sub n's
is positive, or at least
non-negative, notice then that
the sequence of partial sums
is monotonic non-decreasing.
Why?
Because to go from the n-th
partial sums to the 'n plus
first' partial sum, you add
on 'a sub 'n plus 1''.
And since 'a sub 'n plus 1''
is at least as big as 0, it
means that the 'n plus first'
partial sum can be no smaller
than the n-th partial sum.
In other words, therefore, if
the series summation 'n' goes
from 1 to infinity, 'a sub n' is
a positive series, it must
either diverge to infinity, or
else it converges to the limit
'L', where 'L' is the least
upper bound for the sequence
of partial sums.
OK?
Now qualitatively, that's
the end of story.
In other words, we
now know what?
For a positive series, it either
diverges to infinity,
or else it converges
to a sum, a limit.
And that limit is what?
The least upper bound for the
sequence of partial sums.
The problem is that
quantitatively, we would like
to have some criteria for
determining whether a positive
series falls into the
first category
or the second category.
Notice, how can we tell whether
the series converges
or whether it diverges?
And you see, the reading
material in the text for this
assignment focuses attention
on three major tests.
And these are the ones I'd like
to go over with you once
lightly, so to speak.
The first test is called
the comparison test.
And it almost sounds
self-evident.
I just want to outline
how these proofs go.
Because I think that once you
hear these things spoken, as
you read the material, the
formal proofs will fit into a
pattern much more nicely than if
you haven't heard the stuff
said out loud, you see.
The idea is this.
Let's suppose that we know that
summation 'n' goes from 1
to infinity, 'C sub n', is a
convergent positive series.
In other words, all of
these are positive,
and the series converges.
Suppose I now have another
sequence of numbers, 'u sub
n', where each 'u sub
n' is positive--
see, it's at least as big as 0--
but can be no bigger than
'C sub n' for each 'n'.
Then the statement is that the
series formed by adding up the
'u sub n's must also converge.
Notice what you're saying is,
here's a bunch of positive
terms that can't
get too large.
And these terms in magnitude
are less
than or equal to these.
Therefore, what you're saying is
that this sum can't get too
large either.
And if you want to verbalize
that so that it becomes more
formal, the idea is this.
Let 'T sub n' denote the n-th
partial sums of the series
involving the 'C sub n's.
In other words, let 'T sub n'
be 'C sub 1' plus et cetera,
up to 'C sub n'.
And let 'S sub n' be the n-th
term in the sequence of
partial sums of the series
involving the 'u's.
In other words, let 'S sub
n' be 'u1' plus et cetera
up to 'u sub n'.
Now the idea is-- lookit.
We know that each of the 'u's
in magnitude is smaller than
each of the 'C's.
Consequently, the sum of all
the 'u's must be no greater
than the sum of all the 'C's.
In other words, n-th partial
sum, 'S sub n', is less than
or equal to the partial sum,
'T sub n' for each 'n'.
Now, by our previous result,
knowing that these series
summation 'C sub n' converges,
it converges to its least
upper bound of partial sums.
In other words, the limit of
'T sub n' as 'n' approaches
infinity is some number 'T',
where 'T' is the least upper
bound of the sequence of partial
sums of the series.
Well in particular, then, since
each 'S sub n' is less
than or equal to 'T sub n', 'S
sub n' itself certainly cannot
exceed the least upper
bound, namely 'T'.
In other words, 'S sub n'
can be no bigger than
'T' for each 'n'.
Well, what does this mean?
It means, then, that
the sequence 'S sub
n' itself is bounded.
Well, it's bounded.
It's a monotonic non-decreasing
sequence.
Therefore, its limit exists.
Not only does it exist, but it's
the least upper bound of
the sequence of partial sums.
In other words, this proof
is given in the text.
All I want you to see is that
step by step, what this proof
really does is it compares
magnitudes of terms.
In other words, if one batch of
terms can't get lodged, if
term by term, everything--
another sequence is less than
these terms, then that second
sum can't get too
large either.
And this is just a formalization
of that.
There are a few notes that we
should make first of all.
Namely, the condition that 'u
sub n' be between 0 and 'C sub
n' for all 'n' can be weakened
to cover the case where this
is true only beyond
a certain point.
Look, let me show you
what I mean by this.
Let's suppose I look at the
sequence 1 plus 1/2 plus 1/3--
let's do at a different one.
1 plus 1/2 plus 1/4 plus 1/8
plus 1/16, et cetera.
In other words, the geometric
series each of
whose terms is 1/2.
This series we know
converges OK.
Now what the comparison test
says is, suppose you have
something like this--
1 plus 1/3 plus 1/5 plus 1/9
plus 1/17, et cetera.
See, notice that each of these
terms is less than the
corresponding term here.
Consequently, since these
terms add up to a finite
amount, these terms
here must also add
up to a finite amount.
But suppose for the sake of
argument I decide to replace
the first term here by
10 to the sixth.
I'll make this a million.
Now notice that this sum is
going to become much larger.
But the point is when I change
this from a 1 to 10 to the
sixth, even though I made the
sum larger, I didn't change
the finiteness of it.
In other words, if I replace the
first four terms here by
fantastically large numbers and
then keep the rest of the
series intact, sure, I've made
to sum very, very large.
But I've only change it by a
finite amount, which will in
effect, not change
the convergence.
That's all I was saying over
here, that the comparison test
really hinges on what?
Beyond a certain term, you
could stop making the
comparison.
And the second observation is
the converse to what we're
talking about.
Namely, if we know that 'u sub
n' is at least as big as 'd
sub n' for each 'n', where the
series summation 'n' goes from
1 to infinity, 'd sub n' is a
positive divergent series,
then this series, summation 'u
sub n', must also diverge
since its convergence would
imply the convergence of this.
In other words, notice that
by the comparison test, if
summation 'u sub n' converged,
the 'd n's, being less than
the 'u n's would mean that
summation 'dn' end would have
to converge also.
At any rate, these are
the two portions of
the comparison test.
And this is what goes into
Now the interesting thing,
or the draw back to the
comparison test is
simply this--
that 99 times out of 100, if
you can find a series to
compare a given series with, you
probably would have known
whether the given series
converged or diverged in the
first place.
In other words, somehow or
other, to find the right
series to compare something with
is a rather subtle thing
if you didn't already know the
right answer to the problem.
Well, at any rate, what I'm
trying to drive at is that the
comparison test has as one of
its features a proof for a
more interesting test-- a test
that's far less intuitive--
called the 'ratio test'.
The ratio test says
the following.
Let's suppose again you're
given a positive series.
What you do now is form a
sequence whereby each term in
the sequence is the
ratio between two
terms in the series.
In other words, what I do is I
form the sequence by taking
the second term divided by the
first term, the third term
divided by the second term, the
fourth term divided by the
third term.
Now let's call that general
term 'u sub n'.
This seems a little bit
abstract for you.
Let's look at a more
tangible example.
Suppose I take the series
summation 'n' goes from 1 to
infinity, '10 to the n'
over 'n factorial'.
Notice that in this case, the
n-th term is '10 to the n'
over 'n factorial'.
The 'n plus first' term is '10
to the 'n plus 1'' over ''n
plus 1' factorial'.
So 'u sub n' is the ratio
of the 'n plus first'
term to the n-th term.
In other words, '10 to the 'n
plus 1'' over ''n plus 1'
factorial' divided by '10 to
the n' over 'n factorial'.
'10 to the 'n plus 1'' divided
by '10 to the n' is simply 10.
And ''n plus 1' factorial'
divided by 'n factorial' is
simply 'n plus 1'.
In other words, observe the
structure of the factorials
that you get from the n-th to
the 'n plus first' simply by
multiplying by 'n plus 1'.
Again, the computational
details will be
left for the exercises.
At any rate, then, in this
particular case, 'u sub n'
would be '10 over 'n plus 1''.
Now here's what the
ratio test says.
Assuming that the limit 'u sub
n' as 'n' approaches infinity
exists, call it 'rho'.
Then, the series converges if
rho less than 1 and diverges
if rho is greater than 1.
And the test fails
if rho equals 1.
In other words, if the terms get
progressively smaller, so
that the ratio and the limit
stays less than 1, then the
series converges.
If on the other hand, the ratio
in the limit exceeds 1,
that means the terms are getting
big fast enough so
that the series diverges.
Let me point out an important
observation here.
Notice the difference between
the limit equaling 1 and each
term of the sequence
being less than 1.
In other words, notice that even
if 'u sub n' is less than
1 for every 'n', rho
may still equal 1.
For example, look at the terms
'n' over 'n plus 1''.
For each 'n', 'n' over 'n
plus 1' is less than 1.
Yet the limit as 'n' approaches
infinity is exactly
equal to 1.
Now again, the formal proof of
this is given in the book.
But I thought if I just take
a few minutes to show you
geometrically what's happening
here, you'll get a better
picture to understand what's
happening in the text.
Let's prove this in the case
that rho is less than 1.
Pictorially, if rho is less than
1, that means there's a
space between rho and 1.
That means I can choose an
epsilon such that rho plus
epsilon, which I'll call it 'r',
is a positive number, but
still less than 1.
Now, by definition of rho
being the limit of the
sequence 'a sub 'n plus 1'' over
'a sub n', that means I
can find the capital 'N' for
this given epsilon, such that
whenever 'n' is greater than
capital 'N', that 'a sub 'n
plus 1' over 'a sub n' is less
than rho plus epsilon.
In other words, is less than
'r', where 'r' is some fixed
number now less than 1.
Now let me apply this to
successive values of 'n'.
In other words, taking
'n' to be capital--
see, looking at this thing here,
taking 'n' to be capital
'N', I have 'a' over capital 'N
plus 1', 'a sub capital 'N
plus 1'' over 'a sub N'
is less than 'r'.
In other words, 'a sub capital
'N plus 1'' is less than 'r'
times 'a sub N'.
Similarly, 'a sub capital 'N
plus 2'' over 'a sub capital
'N plus 1'' is also
less than 'r'.
In other words, 'a sub capital
'N plus 2'' is less than 'r'
times 'a sub capital
'N plus 1''.
But 'a sub 'N plus 1'' in
turn is less than 'r'
times 'a sub N'.
Putting this in here, 'a sub
'N plus 2' is less than 'r
squared' times 'a sub N'..
At any rate, if I now sum these
inequalities, you see
what I get is what?
The limit as we go from 'n plus
1' to infinity-- in other
words, the tail end of
this particular sum
is less than what?
Well, I can factor out the
'a sub N' over here.
And what's left inside
is what?
'r' plus 'r squared' plus
'r cubed', et cetera.
But this particular series is a
convergent geometric series.
In other words, this must
converge because this
converges, and this is less
than, term by term,
the terms over here.
In other words, notice that the
proof of the ratio test
hinges on knowing two things,
the comparison test and the
convergence of a geometric
series.
Again, the reason I go through
this as rapidly as I do is
that every detail is done
magnificently in the textbook.
All I want you to see here is
the overview of how these
tests come about.
Finally, we have another
powerful test called the
'integral test'.
And the integral test
essentially equates positive
series with improper
integrals.
By the way, I have presented the
material, so to speak, in
the order of appearance
in the textbook.
You see, the comparison test,
ratio test, and integral test
are given in that order
in the text.
And so, I kept the
same order here.
However, it's interesting to
point out that the integral
test, in a way, is a companion
of the comparison test.
And let me show you first
of all what the
integral test says.
It says, and I've written out
the formal statements here.
I'll show you pictorially what
this means in a moment.
But it says, suppose there is
a decreasing continuous
function, 'f of x'.
Notice the word continuous
in here.
That guarantees that we can
integrate 'f of x'.
Such that 'f' evaluated at each
integral value of 'x',
say 'x' equals 'n', is 'u sub
n', where 'u sub n' is the
n-th term of the positive
series 'u1'
plus 'u2', et cetera.
Then, what the integral test
says is that the series
summation 'n' goes from 1 to
infinity 'u sub n', and the
integral 1 to infinity, ''f
of x' dx', either converge
together or diverge together.
In other words, we can test
a particular series for
convergence by knowing
whether a particular
improper integral converges.
And to show you what this
thing means pictorially,
simply observe this.
See, what we're saying is,
suppose that when you plot the
terms of the series--
so, 'u1', 'u2', 'u3', 'u4'--
that these happen to be the
integral values of a
continuous curve, 'y' equals
'f of x', which not only
passes through these points, but
is a continuous decreasing
function as this happens.
Then what the statement is is
that the sum of these lengths
converges if and only
if the area under
the curve is finite.
And the proof go something
like this.
It's a rather ingenious
type of thing.
You see, notice that if this
height is 'u sub 1', and the
base of the rectangle is 1,
notice that numerically, the
area of the rectangle--
it's quite in general.
If the base of a rectangle is 1,
numerically the area of the
rectangle equals the height,
because the area is the base
times the height.
If the base is 1, the area
equals the height.
So the idea is simply this.
Lookit.
Suppose, for example,
that we look at this
diagram over here.
Notice that in this diagram,
if we stop at n, the area
under this curve is the integral
from 1 to 'n', or 1
to 'n plus 1', because of how
these lines are drawn.
See, notice that the first
height stops at the number 2.
The second base stops at
number 3, et cetera.
The idea is this, though, that
the area under the curve in
general, from 1 to 'n plus 1',
is integral from 1 to 'n plus
1', ''f of x' dx'.
On the other hand, the area of
the rectangles are what?
'u1' plus 'u2' plus
'u3', up to 'u n'.
In other words, for any given
'n', 'u1' up to u n' is
greater than or equal to this
particular integral.
Consequently, taking the
limit as 'n' goes to
infinity, we get what?
The summation 'u n' is greater
than or equal to integral from
one to infinity ''f of x' dx'.
Consequently, if this integral
diverges, meaning that this
gets very large, the fact that
this can be no less than this
means that this too
must also diverge.
Correspondingly, if we now do
the same problem, but draw the
thing slightly differently,
notice that now in this
particular picture, the area
under the curve is integral
from 1 to 'n', ''f of x' dx'.
On the other hand, the area of
the rectangles are what?
It's 'u2' plus 'u3'
up to 'u n'.
But now you see the rectangles
are inscribed under the curve.
Consequently, 'u2' plus et
cetera, up to 'u n', is less
than this integral.
Therefore, if I add 'u1' onto
both sides, the sum 'u1', et
cetera, up to 'u n', is less
than 'u1' plus integral 1 to
'n', ''f of x' dx'.
If I now take the limit as n
goes to infinity, you see this
becomes summation un.
n goes from 1 to infinity.
This becomes integral from 1
to infinity, ''f of x' dx'.
And therefore, if this now
converges, the sum on the
right is finite.
Since the sum on the left cannot
exceed the sum on the
right, the sum on the left
must also be finite.
Consequently, the convergence
of the integral implies the
convergence of the series.
Again, I apologize for doing
this this rapidly.
All I wanted you to do was
to get an idea of what's
happening here.
Because as I say, the book is
magnificent in this section.
The proofs are very well
self-contained.
At any rate, this gives us three
rather powerful tests,
which I will drill you on in
the exercises for testing
convergence of positive
series.
What we're going to do next time
is to come to grips with
a much more serious problem.
And that is, what do you do if
the series isn't positive?
But that's another story.
And so until next
time, good bye.
Funding for the publication of
this video was provided by the
Gabriella and Paul Rosenbaum
Foundation.
Help OCW continue to provide
free and open access to MIT
courses by making a donation
at ocw.mit.edu/donate.